let's try another bot
how about myself where am i actually there i am
okay let's see how that works
okay london it is
that looks like a positional
concession so c3 e6 okay uh
yeah should i go b3 and a4 and all that or just
let's go bishop e2
and um with 95.
yeah it's kind of fun to use the third person
and say let's see what he does but this is me
ah like that okay
and what am i supposed to do here so one
thing is rook takes b2 bishop b2 knight c4
bishop c3 rook d1 and a check but do
i have enough for an exchange i don't
know the other is just deploying
knight e4 and then maybe queen g4
already then i'm getting worried
he will castle oh that's annoying
i hate it when i do this to
myself is that how it goes
okay let's do that and see
oh that's annoying i didn't even see that was
possible i thought he had to move the knight
uh what am i gonna do now
knight f6 isn't gonna work
queen g4 king h8 knight g5 looks looks
like i'm desperate which i probably am
okay let's do if i go knight d6 he does what b5
or does he just play knight d3
nope he takes
i could try to simplify into some end game
ed6 knight d3 this is so annoying being
outplayed by yourself that's ridiculous
okay let's do that
then let's do that
and we should like take only five
oh this is go queen takes p7
just desperately trying to
weasel a draw out of this one
okay what can i do
oh is he going to cheap on me with everything
can i grovel with queen a7 with the one d1 in b2
i would doubt it so let's move ah but then he just
gets windy oh no he's letting me have this pawn
maybe that gives me a glimmer of hope
or maybe it doesn't he's just gonna go
between
i don't think this is going to end well uh what
can i do rook fd1 would that get me anywhere
okay let's try to go to b3
hopefully can i i wish i could go to
c2 now but i have a feeling i can't
so let's go queen c2 but then he
goes queen c4 okay let's do that
then if i go here what does it do the
key one he's gonna go queen b2 over
okay let's see how this goes
he is gonna go queen b2
so what have i got here
i don't immediately see the
reputation of rook c2 but
well what can i do
okay that's all very well but
if i approach with my king
okay let me step back
not really sure what the hell i'm doing
can i okay let's go before
and am i going to be lost because he's
gonna come kings so let me put the rook here
then if i come here what we're gonna do
can i go k3 does that help
f5 okay should i take the pawn and then
it should be a draw or maybe i can
go b5 and try to be pretty about it
either might be an f4 check ah let's
just take the pawn and hope for the best
i'm not sure what that pt move
is for but let me get in g3
and
let's go here maybe i should have gone h4
okay let's go up the board and
see if that helps a little bit
oh i can get some checks in now
i don't even know where my piece is anymore
let me go eight oh that was unfortunate
because i've allowed him to get his pawn to
h3 and then my h2 pawn is going to be weak
and suddenly this position isn't
looking even remotely defensible anymore
okay still i would rather be active
than passive so let's go with that
okay
and let's try attacking his pawn for a while
oh is he gonna go rook
this has got to be the silliest
cheapo of all time okay
you know i can't tell if i'm a complete
nitwit or what the hell is going on
what am i supposed to do should be it should
be a fairly simple draw by now i think
but i think i can still mess it up badly
okay for what it's worth let's go there and
hope for the best and let's take that pawn
let's grovel back
and see oh h2 and g3 oh
damn
i'm not sure why he's doing this okay
yeah unfortunately f3 would be too clever by half
and what can i do it's gonna
go king g6 and rook at 7.
yeah you can trust your computer
to find a even simple win
i have no idea what is why is not
doing some sort of obvious thing but maybe
this is better technique what should i do now
can i go f5
i have to do something and then grovel back
drawable back
oh wow my bot is as lousy in technique as i am
my bot did not impress in this one
so because i'm playing my bot uh i
should assume that my technique will
be as bad as his and so maybe i shouldn't
celebrate yet but okay let's try the check
and let's try a check again nice one
century a nice one let's go there
let's give a check over there
not sure what he hopes to accomplish with this
when can i get f3 in can i get root j and f3 or
should i just go to the side let's go to the side
i like the way he's just left a fixed
response do you believe in this check so
oh it's so irritating when computers force you to
play all 80 moves so whatever
the hell they make you play
maybe i can actually play king h two
am i blundering something again let's
uh no i can't be blundering anything now
let me get the eighth rank
that's always a nice one to have
because then i check him again
yes i believe in this check
yeah it feels like i should be able to play f3
somewhere here but let's go there oh here f3
but he'll go to b2 check let's try
king g3 you can always squiggle back
the next one okay so now i can play f3 and unless
i'm seriously mistaken this should be just yes
let's come back
and let's go there
okay
even his understanding is bad as bad as
mine he's continuing to play with rooks
this is a magnus thing
check
my deep study of pancura i think
i can now hold this position
finally
well i'm very impressed uh that my
bots technique is as bad as mine
that's a kind of touch of authenticity right there